[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Matt Hassell back ESPN
NFL analyst and contributor to Sunday
NFL Countdown he's on the panel with
Randy Moss and Teddy brewski Rex Ryan
Sam Ponder Saturday and Sunday of super
Wild Card Weekend you can watch them at
10 A.M Eastern both days on the
mothership good to see you again Matt
let me start with the poll question
Seton give Matt the poll question today
what team was most disappointing this
season your options were and there's a
bunch of them
all right come on
most disappointing oh it's obvious
Denver for me it's Denver I mean people
were picking the Denver Broncos to win
the Super Bowl
um but that was just I think it shocked
everybody
I'm curious who you would put ahead of
Denver I would say Green Bay because I
think everybody thought the NFC was open
for the taking and you know you lost
Devonte Adams but you still had a good
defense good running attack and you had
some young receivers in there yeah they
lost Devonte Adams I feel like we talked
about that a lot you know last year I
think everyone just said that the Denver
Broncos are a franchise quarterback away
from being a Super Bowl Contender they
go out and give Russell Wilson basically
a quarter of a billion dollars they go
get a new uh head coach who was you know
Aaron Rodgers BFF in Green Bay and I
think you expected that to be the you
know they had everything else and we
also thought that was going to be the
best division in football and that
division was I mean that was a huge
disappointment so no I I I mean just one
vote but I'm I'm giving it to the Denver
Broncos is that job
enticing to like Sean Payton Denver
if you want to be married to Russell
Wilson it's enticing you know and so
there are some coaches that have a
vision for to how to get him back to be
a player that is one of the better
quarterbacks in the league not one of
the worst quarterbacks in the league and
so if you have that Vision then yeah
it's a great job but if you're a guy
like Pete Carroll maybe be an example of
hey that I don't want that that's not
what I want what I want is just a legion
of boom type defense great special teams
and a running game that can travel and
then every once in a while we'll we'll
take our shots our quarterback will use
his legs every once in a while not
playground ball but like you know but
honestly the way Geno Smith played this
year Geno Smith played so well this year
he played like Russell Wilson had
previously always played and uh and
that's the formula that Pete Carroll is
looking for he's not looking for you
know a quarterback that can cook so to
speak but if you're Seattle you got the
fifth pick in the draft
are you are you amazing are you signing
up Gino Smith and for how long and you
use that fifth pick on a quarterback
I think you can do both things I think
Gino quarterback Gino Smith has earned
the right to be the quarterback of the
Seattle Seahawks there's no doubt about
that
um you know at a certain price for sure
but but I think he has earned the right
and it's really funny because had the
Detroit Lions not knocked off the Green
Bay Packers I think a lot of the talk
would have been like oh Gino couldn't
have even got him into the playoffs but
since the Detroit Lions knocked off the
Green Bay Packers now the Seahawks are
in the playoffs I know firsthand Pete
Carroll can do some damage once he gets
in the tournament and Geno Smith really
he played I thought he played
outstanding this year I was really
really impressed with how he played but
so now the narrative is like oh Geno
Smith you're breaking these records he's
got his teams in the playoffs like he
could do damage and I believe he can
like I I think Geno Smith you know the
thrower has been great the leader has
been great and the guy using his legs
when necessary has really been
underrated as well so yeah he's the guy
now if you want to develop a younger guy
along the way but like that could be
Drew lock and you could spend your money
elsewhere but no huge huge credit to
what the Seattle Seahawks have done this
year
um based on how everyone was talking
about them at the end of last year or
even the start of this year
body language Aaron Rodgers walking off
the field last night told you what
um he's a human being that
um this I'll say this when you're the
quarterback of a franchise just the
regular starting quarterback franchise
quarterback the weight of the world is
on you during the season it's seven days
a week it's all of it so now try try to
become
uh Aaron Rodgers like maybe the best
quarterback that's ever played for that
franchise certainly one of them and now
the weight of what every move that he
makes that gets scrutinized you could
see the weight of it like a big exhale
this has been a hard season and I would
just say this in my NFL career some
years were easier than others like if I
was healthy throughout the season it was
a lot of fun like I had a I had a blast
but if I was dealing with like a broken
thumb or broken ribs or a sprained jaw
or like some random thing it's like it
takes the joy out of football a little
bit it makes it feel like a job it makes
it feel like work instead of making it
feel like fun I'm playing a kids game
and so I think there was a lot on Aaron
Rodgers this year that way and and he
probably quite honestly I think that's
probably the last time he'll play for
the Green Bay Packers
that's what I wondered that's why I was
reading the body language that he almost
was taking it in somebody wanted to swap
jerseys with him and he says no I'm
keeping this one well if you're playing
next season I don't if anything I would
want to shed that Jersey that I just
wore and we just lost and we didn't make
the playoffs is that fair to read into
it like that
you know what I think there's such
finality at the at the end of any season
when you don't know it I mean listen I I
was on the stinking practice squad when
I started out in Green Bay and then I
was the backup quarterback but the
starting holder I mean for field goals
and extra points and I remember it was a
game I think it was Christmas Eve maybe
but like we're playing Tampa and it was
my last game ever as a packer as the
holder on field goals I remember you
know we'd shake hands with the team we
say a prayer with the other team we walk
off the field and I remember just
soaking it in because that atmosphere is
so special there anyone that's ever been
to Lambeau knows exactly what I'm
talking about and I'm walking off the
field for the last time a game that I
literally was holding extra points and
field goals for Ryan Longwell and I mean
obviously you know and I was getting
like a little bit choked up I'm like wow
this has been such a special experience
if I get traded or if I'm on a different
team next year I want to remember this
and that was me like three years in
Green Bay we're talking about air Aaron
Rodgers he's probably looking up there
like I wonder where they're going to put
my name are they going to fit it in
between Bart Star and reynichki well Don
Hudson's got a spot next to him oh what
about Reggie White you know like it's
completely different so I mean he's a
human being in every talk show and every
you know we're going to talk about it
all off season but
um these are real people and and he's no
different we're talking about Hasselbeck
ESPN NFL analyst and in the postseason
NFL countdowns the place to go with
Randy Moss Teddy brewski Rex Ryan and
Sam Ponder they'll be there on Saturday
and Sunday of Wild Card Weekend 10 a.m
Eastern on both days would you have had
a problem if the Texans decided to take
a knee on the two-point conversion heck
yeah I would have had a problem heck
yeah
um but I also wouldn't have had a
problem if they tried like a trick play
and they acted like they were going for
an extra point and then they ran a trick
play they ran the fake field goal that
they you know they have in the Playbook
they've been practicing It All season
it's week 18. it would be legendary like
that's kind of what I actually was
hoping for uh not just some like random
two-point play you know a five-yard
tight end out route but no listen I'll
say this like you know I know fans and
people in the media and all that should
take already thinking about the draft
but when you're a football player like
you're competing and those guys in that
locker room every locker room that I was
in I don't care if you're playing rock
paper scissors for your per diem money
like you care and you're competitive
that's why you are where you are in your
career you're in the career that you're
in so this idea of sort of like tanking
or not trying your best
um I don't know if they do that in other
sports it's certainly not something I've
ever ever even felt an inkling towards
with coaches or players in in the NFL
if you're the Cowboys you're Mike
McCarthy Dak Prescott what are you
taking away from that loss in Washington
going into good lesson because they they
look like the absolute worst team worst
playoff team
um yesterday and this would be this is
you know what it looked like to me it
looked like the third preseason game
that's what it looked like to me and and
having sort of made this mistake myself
in my career
sometimes in the preseason the head
coach I remember Mike Holmgren would say
Okay starters you're going to play uh
you're gonna play a quarter and a half
or something like that like we're not
resting you we're playing you but you're
not really all the way in just the goal
is to get out of this game healthy you
know and
the mindset like for me anyway I
couldn't I wasn't a very good player if
I was sort of like playing not to get
hurt I had to be all the way freaking in
all the way in I needed to be like
confident throw and throw the ball with
conviction uh play tough and gritty and
like
basically you know how you would
normally play football in the preseason
it's almost like ah yeah this is a
little different and you got one foot in
one foot out it's a terrible way to play
you don't look like the kind of player
that you are and I thought the Dallas
Cowboys in the Run game they stunk uh
they really stunk in a lot of areas it
was bad quarterback play for a
quarterback that's not a bad player so I
think there's a lesson there uh will it
affect them going forward in the next
week nope it's probably a lesson they
learned for next year maybe but um but
they really look bad and they're and
they're not a bad team what do you do if
you're Sean McVay
I don't think he's going to coach next
year I really don't and I've spent a
little bit of time with Sean McVay and I
didn't know him before I did and then
the first time I met him I'm like wow
this guy is a genius he's a grinder like
when does he sleep
um
at some point like it's just too much
like you need a breather like listen I
coach High School football this year and
every loss I took really hard it's tough
I don't know if people understand the
grind that coaching is and then when
you're sort of uh I don't call him a
micromanager but he he could tell you
what the nickel Defender is supposed to
do in every scenario it's like almost
like it's almost too much and so like I
could see him he's 36 years old I
believe I could see him taking a
breather and then being the hottest name
in the coaching search coach searches
from here on out and he'll take a step
back some coaches have taken a step back
taken a year off Doug Peterson Mike
McCarthy Tom Coughlin a bunch of guys
and they've come back a better version
of themselves and uh you know it would
stink for the Rams would stink for the
NFL but I could definitely see that
happening with uh with Sean more likely
to be in TV next year not on TV but Tom
Brady or Sean McVay not neither I I
don't I think Tom Brady is going to play
again
um and listen that was sort of be my
advice to him like you know I retired
when I was 40 and uh went into TV I
joined Sunday NFL Countdown they offered
me a job to sit with Chris Berman on
that show and I'm like Chris Berman are
you kidding me like that was my favorite
show Growing Up that's my favorite show
is an adult you know and then like oh
you can sit next to Chris Berman I'm
like okay fine I'm in
um but as cool as that was there's
nothing like playing quarterback in the
NFL there really isn't and so
um if if you can make it work for your
family like part of my thing was my kids
were teenagers I had kids entering high
school and I'm trying to be a
quarterback in the NFL it's it's a
different Dynamic but as long as you can
really get Mastery of that situation and
do both of those things well I would I
would keep playing you think Sean
McVeigh is just going to take a year off
not take a year off and go into TV I
think he would be awesome at TV like I
know he would be great I mean again and
like say when I sat down with him the
first time they were getting ready to
play a game in Mexico City and I sat
down we were supposed to watch a little
bit of film for like five minutes like
two hours and five minutes later I'm
like I I feel like I should be paying
you money I'm learning so much can I
write some of this down it was so it was
so awesome he would be amazing on TV but
I don't think that's what he needs I
think he needs to step back and take a
breather and
I don't know what learn some stuff about
how to maybe have a healthier balance
maybe delegate a little bit more maybe
not take the losses so hard I mean good
people that I know well that I have a
ton of respect for I mentioned the names
Tom Coughlin Mike McCarthy Doug Peterson
have taken a year out of football and
come back way better way better and I
think they would tell you that and and
healthier too
um and so Sean McVay I think is one of
the best coaches I've ever been around
um in terms of like the potential to be
great and I think I think that would
probably I don't think TV is what he
needs
um even though we would love to have him
all right rapid fire here I'll give you
a Bengals Chiefs or bills ah man like
those are like my three favorite teams I
I love those teams and I think I'm in
love with those quarterbacks Joe Burrows
the hottest quarterback in in football
right now like if you I I didn't know it
I'm doing this feature for Joe burrow
it's coming out soon I think it's going
to run this week or next week it is so
cool the stuff I learned about Joe Bro
and his fundamentals like this dude
makes things that are uncool look cool
on the football field too
um but I say that in like I'm the huge
Patrick Mahomes fan Josh Allen's
probably my favorite quarterback to
watch
um those three guys like we're living in
just an amazing time where we get to see
those guys play if if like I've said
this last year if that AFS if that game
against the bills and the Chiefs was the
Super Bowl last year I would have been
fine like if you were like you know what
we're just gonna do that game again as
the Super Bowl I would have been like
thank you this is the best Super Bowl
I've ever watched I'll give you the
Eagles or the field
I like the eagles and I like a Jalen a
healthy Jalen hurts I've had that injury
and he looked he looked like yesterday
like I felt when I tried to play with
that injury
um hopefully he gets healthy in time
that buys big are the Niners better with
Brock Purdy I think so I think so he's
the real deal he needs to be taken
seriously and uh that's that's crazy to
say but um like I said earlier Pete
Carroll has a formula and a vision of
how he wants to run his team Kyle
Shanahan has the exact same thing and
Brock bird he's fitting into that
perfectly right now I said Matt's my
favorite Hasselbeck haven't I poem Oh
for decades yeah yeah yeah great
appearance man wait you've seen you seem
a little uh suspicious about that
no I the you know it's it's High Praise
You know I was thinking about my wife my
younger brother a lot of people like
Rich Eisen would tell you and I know
you're friends with rich Rich Eisen
would tell you that my youngest brother
Nathaniel who people don't know about
because he doesn't work on television
um he's his favorite and and most people
would usually say that but but people
like friends of ours like people who
know us always say my wife so it's uh
you know it's uh it all depends but I I
thank you for the compliment I would I
would have said your dad because I'm in
more of that era having actually seen
your dad play football but uh I get that
a lot like Adrian wojanowski who covers
NBA at ESPN like I don't know him well
the first time I met him at work he was
like Hey I was a big fan of your dad's
growing up or Jeffrey Lurie uh who is
the owner of the Philadelphia Eagles the
first time I met him down there he was
like I was a season ticket holder for
the Patriots I used to love your dad and
Steve Grogan and Russ Francis I'm like
you know oh that's awesome I appreciate
it next time we'll have Matt's wife on
on fritzy when you book them we'll get
married you won't like that she doesn't
like the camera
have fun this weekend thank you again
Matt anytime Matt Hasselbeck NFL
Countdown with the Randy Moss Teddy
brewski Rex Ryan and Sam Ponder Saturday
and Sunday Wild Card Weekend they start
at 10 A.M Eastern both days on the
mothership take a break we've got our
play of the day your phone calls coming
up right after this